today's question comes from jamie in
indiana we follow the ramsay plan with
our finances
and are trying to teach our young
children the same principles we have a
chore chart and are learning
that they must work to get paid however
every time we see my parents
they give our children money it's
becoming
difficult to keep them engaged in the
lessons we are trying to teach when
grandparents just hand them cash
how do we handle this situation you know
i've not started doing that yet i should
do that
i should mess up your parenting by
giving the kids cash no
no it's like the swing set example
that's always what i always tell people
at christmas that year when denise asked
for a swing
and you know about a swing set she was
like i just want to fish your price
baby swing that's all i want and i'll go
and we and we literally looked at each
other and made the knees were like oh it
begins
here it is so it probably dave just
throws up
just went overboard and just yeah no but
but honestly jamie i'm like this
this is a this is a people have this
question a lot because grandparents
have the entitlement as they feel to do
whatever they want
with the children and then they send
them on home and you're like
oh we have a bedtime all of this but
um you know i wouldn't be crazy uptight
jamie i mean i think
depending on the age of your kids and
depending on how much they're doing it
if they're just kind of having fun with
them there is a level where i give grace
to grandparents where they can love on
the kids but if you find that it's
truly affecting like their character and
they
really really really are saying like i
want to do chores because i can just go
to mimi and papa's and they just give me
money
then yeah then we probably want to
circle back and have a conversation with
the grandparents your parents
to say hey this is what we're trying to
implement in our home
and because of your generosity and your
big wonderful hearts
it is kind of messing with it but again
i'm so balanced in this because i know
some people jamie i'm not saying this is
you
can that are on the rams plane are very
legalistic like no if you do not
remember and then they don't allow any
amount of like gifts or grandparents to
be grandparents there's a level of that
that is life but if it goes to the
extreme
then yeah you may want to circle back
and have a conversation yeah
yeah and i i think um the question i
always ask
is um is this
really about you and your mom or is this
really about the kids getting money
and is there something else going on
that's a doctor john deloney thing
that's uh not really a money
grandparents i don't know how you know
it's just like your mother is
overbearing
and this is one example where she's out
of control
and has no boundaries and uh so you
decide to use this one to come down on
that overall issue
and so yeah if that's going on then
that's this is not the
way to fight the fight you got to fight
the fight a different way on that yep
so but again it's not going to screw it
up the
other thing i will say is this um
they can go uh to the next door
neighbors
and eat ice cream and you find out about
it later and you don't allow ice cream
because of your nutritional beliefs or
whatever i'm making up some bizarre
example here but
i mean the kids are and that does not
give them permission to come home and
demand ice cream
so you know the the reason we teach
children how to handle money is not
really about money
it's really about them building a
generosity muscle building a saving
muscle
building a wise spending muscle
building a work ethic and so when we put
shores on the refrigerator we're going
to
incentivize you on the positive side
with money
but at the end of the day you're still
going to do the freaking chores
because it is my job as your dad to make
you learn how to work
so that when you grow up you don't live
in my basement
and so i can explain that to a
four-year-old i could explain it to a
six-year-old i can explain it to a
12-year-old
that yes your meme and papa gave you
some money but we do this thing with
money here because i'm trying to teach
you that money comes from work not me me
and papa
you're not going to get a trust fund
that you're going to live on the back of
a yacht
so you're going to have to learn to work
puppy and so i'm going to work with you
on that so yes they give you money and
that's nice but it doesn't
give you an exemption right from feeding
the dog
that's right that's your chore yeah and
so i'm going to play
honey this is why i'm teaching you this
honey you're going to do this
it's not really nice of you that you're
telling the why
you know there you go when rachel was
little it was just no
just shut up and do it yeah do it oh
well now we're going to explain the why
you turned off you turned out no this is
so good this is so good
no but really it and then it just
becomes the point of disobedience that's
that's the hard thing
because you do have kids like mine i'm
like they're so different one is
motivated to do it and should clean the
playroom she's like do i get my dollar
like she
and the other one just basically the
compliant one and the rebellious yes
yes so you're gonna deal with that
anyway yeah oh by the way when you tell
the rebellious one to do something and
why
and they don't do it then you just tell
them they have to do it anyway all they
remember is that part
maybe so just in case maybe so just in
case
things do circle back the middle the
middle child and not in my family now
you got it
you guys i am now you guys kidding me
you got you as a middle child
fortunately
i'm really sorry you're you're your
middle one is
absolutely wonderful
she is a rock star
[Music]
she is so sweet and so
tough already she's her mom made over
it's great so yeah yeah that's a good
question because the boundary thing with
grandparents
is uh uh daloni and i were laughing
about this on the air the other day the
christmas when i bought all the kids
those big plastic cars and none of them
are big enough to drive them yet
yes and the whole living room is full of
them and it's like i completely overdid
it i loved it and nobody loved it but me
i was the only one that had two they can
barely expect they can't they can't even
get into it they can't walk yet but i
got to work hard
yeah so um yeah it's yeah you got to
have boundaries somewhere
but uh brand new one of the questions
baloney and i had was a new
baby the first grand baby oh yeah
and that's the one that's the one where
you learn all of this stuff interacting
with your grown kids
and your grandkids and how it's going to
turn out